Advocate prabakar ra
Hegde Advocate hingorani DCP
Saka distinguished guests present here
today our elders brothers and
sisters we would after the question
answer session request our distinguished
guests to present their Impressions on
the topic and their
comments kindly state your name and
profession before putting forward your
question to get a more appropriate
response non-muslim guests would be
given first preference in putting
forward their questions yes
brother thank you Dr Nik for your
Lucid explanation of Islam's concept of
God my simple question is you have
talked about racial Brotherhood
linguistic Brotherhood blood Brotherhood
and so on and they are the disturbers of
the concept of universal Brotherhood but
you have not talked on the concept of
kair I think which is one of the most
important disturbers of universal
Brotherhood in the
world can I have your name brother so I
can answer you in a better way yes
Professor Niger from B
College the professor has asked a
question that I have spoken about
various concept I've explained the
concept unival Brotherhood and spoken
that the concept of Brotherhood based on
blood relationship on Race on cast and
Creed Etc they cause disturbance I
haven't spoken on the concept of
kafir brother kafir is an Arabic word
which comes from the root word KU which
means to
conceal to conceal to hide it also means
to
reject and in context in Islamic context
it means that any person who conceals or
rejects the truth of Islam anyone who
reject the truth of Islam is called as a
kafir anyone who rejects the truth of
Islam that there's one God and Allah
subhana wa tal all that is spoke he's a
cfir any Brotherhood besides the
Brotherhood of universal Brotherhood of
faith and the Islamic brotherhood if if
it falls in other Brotherhood based on
anything there can be 100 types of
Brotherhood Brotherhood based on
particular region whether it be India
whether it be Pakistan whether it be
America all these other
Brotherhood that is not in the purview
of the Brotherhood of faith believ in
concept of one God disturbs the
universal Brotherhood including if you
say that the cfirs the Brotherhood of
kafirs do they disob they disturb what
the meaning of kafir anyone Rejects the
truth of Islam there are some
non-muslims who ask me questions and
doing question answer one of the C they
said that why do the Muslims abuse Us by
calling kafir and people say that that
gets hurt I said see kafir is Arabic
word which means the person who rejects
the truth of Islam it's Arabic word for
a person who reject the truth of Islam
in English if have to translate he
becomes a non-muslim so person a
non-muslim who reject the truth of Islam
he's called as a kafir it's just a
translation of the English word
non-muslim so if you say that don't call
A non-muslim A kafir how can I do that
so if a person says why do you call me a
cafir don't call me a cafir so I can
tell that you accept Islam and stop
calling you a cafir it's only Arabic
word for non-muslim hope that answerers
the
question yes brother satal malani I
think Dr Zak is playing with
ver it's jugy of ver only Islam divides
peoples of the whole
world in two one is M and there is
kafir definitely we don't believe and
trust in many things which Islam
says so this Brotherhood of universal
Brotherhood is not possible what Islam
wants to enjoin Upon
Us Islam only creates
divisive forces even we can know Shia
sunnis and 70 other cast in Islam itself
question huh I'm putting the question
problem un Islam cannot give un it's
only Hinduism which can give Universal
Brotherhood which you have just
quoted Islam does not recognize killing
the cows killing the cfirs taking their
property loot wom folk Islam tells how
Brotherhood can come and you talk of
Brotherhood is a jug jug of ver only
really speaking you are talking Hinduism
in the name of
Islam the brother has made several
comments and Islam
says for verily Allah is with those who
are patient for Brotherhood to Prevail
you should be patient if I'm not patient
there'll be a fight between me and my
brother Islam says
in Bak chapter number 2 verse number
153 forly Allah is with those who are
patient and for brother to Prevail you
should be
patient and I I respect my elderly
brother out here he may be having a good
study of Hinduism but I'm sorry that I
disagree with him his study of Islam is
a bit weak I would say and I do agree
with him that Islam there are two types
of people one is a Believer M and the
other he said is a CF according to
him in every religion there are two
types of people even Hinduism a Hindu
and a
non-hindu in Christianity Christian and
non-Christian in Judaism a Jew and a
non-jew in Islam a Muslim and non-muslim
so where does Islam
differ and I'm not here to criticize
Hinduism I'm not here to criticize
but since you're are a learned speaker I
don't like to speak on Hinduism because
I am a student of comparative studies
I've read The Vedas I've read theard but
if just for a small comment according to
the way mentioned that the humankind has
been created from four parts of almighty
God from the head it the
Brahman from the chest is the shatas
from the thigh is the wayas the business
class and from the feet is the sudra
cast system I'm not here to comment on
these brother I wouldn't like to I
wouldn't like to hurt the feelings of my
Hindu brother Islam doesn't agree with
that I didn't comment on those things I
didn't criticize any religion I didn't
criticize any religion I didn't say that
this religion is wrong but you if you
know your Veda very well you should
testify to the audience doesn't the Veda
say that from the head you have the
brahmins from the chest you have the
chhatria from the thighs you have the
waya the business class learnning class
warrior class business class sudas the
sh are supposed to be downtrodden and
there are books written by Dr edar I
don't to go into the details brother
Hinduism I have learned very well I
respect many aspects of Hinduism certain
aspects I don't agree I have to say
because they have forced me to say Quran
says in Surah Anam 6: 108 revile not
those who worship God besides Allah let
in the ignorance they will revile Allah
subhana tala what I spoke is the
positive aspect of
Hinduism that is the believe in the
concept of one God regarding a question
that you know the Muslims they
keep on killing people they keep on
killing cow you said correct you said
that see every allegation requires an
answer time doesn't permit I'll just
pick up a few any other you can come
next and ask I'm here to clarify the
misconception it's my pleasure only if I
clarify the misconception will the
person understand Islam better therefore
in our sessions we always have a
question on session and we welcome when
anyone criticizes us I love it or more
person criticizes and more is logically
convinced will he understand Islam
better that's what I do Islam said
spread the message of
Truth with the Quran says in 16
125 that is invite all the way of thy
Lord with wisdom and beautiful preaching
and argue with them and reason with them
in the ways that are best most gracious
regarding the concept of can we have
nonage talking about killing cows Etc
and there are many non-muslims who say
you know you Muslims you all are
Ruthless People you all kill animals
just for your information brother a
Muslim can be a very good Muslim even by
being a pure
vegetarian it's not compulsory that he
should have nonv to be a good Muslim but
since the Quran says in several places
you can have the cattle why we shouldn't
have the Quran says in Surah ma chapter
number 5 verse number one it says
that oh you believe fulfill F all your
obligations and lawful for you are all
four-footed animal with the exceptions
named Quran says in Surah Nel chapter
number 16 verse number five that Allah
has created for you
cattles which are his signs from it you
derive warmth and there are various
benefits in it and of the meat you can
eat Quran repeat this in Surah M 23: 211
you can eat the meat of the cattle you
know in
nonv there are doctors available here
even I'm a medical doctor it's rich in
protein it's rich in
iron and it's very
nutritious in the other food the level
of protein which you get in nonv you
cannot get in any other vegetarian food
soy bean which is supposed to be the
best form of protein in vegetable it
comes nowhere close to the non-w protein
and regarding the concept of killing of
cows if you read the Hindu scriptures
I'm not here to criticize any religion
but brother ask question question have
to speak the
truth it permits a person to have non
wage if you read the Hindu scripture the
sages and S they had nonage they even
had beef it is later on due to the
influence of the other religions like
jism Etc that people were being
influenced in the philosophy of Aima of
not to kill
animals that they accepted this
philosophy in the way of life otherwise
Islam is also for animal rights I can
give a talk only on animal rights Islam
is the religion which says they do not
overburden the animals treat them nicely
give them food but when required they
even created for food if you analyze the
other religions which believe in this
philosophy that you should not have
nonage the philosophy was based on the
concept that you should not kill animals
because the living creatures therefore
having nonage is a sin I do agree with
them if any human being can live in this
world without killing a single living
creature I would be the first
one the universal
bout in Hinduism is that every living
creature is your brother every living
creature irrespective whether it's an
animal or a bird or insect I'm asking a
simple question that how can a person
even survive for 5 minutes without
killing millions of his brothers those
who know Medical Science will understand
what I'm saying that whenever you
breathe there are millions of germs
you're inhaling and you're killing
that means in this religion you're
killing your brothers to
survive the universal Brotherhood in
Islam is every human being is your
brother brother in faith is every Muslim
is a brother every living creature is
not my brother but we have to protect
the living creature should not harm them
should not unnecessary torture them but
when required you can have them for food
so when the philosophy says that having
nonv is a sin because you K Liv in
creatures today's science tells us
that even the plants have got life do
you know that so the logic that killing
living creature is a sin has
failed so now now they change the logic
and they say that see plants have got
life but plants can't feel pain
therefore killing the animals is a
greater sin as compared to killing
plants do you know today science has
advanced and we have come to know even
the plants can feel pain the plants can
even cry
the plant even feel happy so the logic
that plants cannot feel pain has failed
what the thing The Cry of the plant
cannot be heard by the human year
because the human year has a frequency
of 20 cycles per second to 20,000 cycles
per second anything between this the
human ear can hear anything below or
above the human ear can't hear for
example if a master blows a dog whistle
you know dog whistle it's called a
silent dog whistle it Blows the Whistle
which has a frequen quency of above
20,000 cycles and Below 40,000 cycles
per second the dog can hear up to 40,000
cycles per second so when the master
Blows the Whistle the dog hears the
whistle but the human being don't hear
it's called as a silent dog whistle
similarly the cry giving out the plant
cannot be heard by the human being but
they also cry they also feel pain there
was a brother of us who argued with
maximum and he told me that brother Zak
I agree with you that the plants have
got life they can feel pain but you know
the plants have got two senses less they
only have three senses the animals have
got five senses therefore killing an
animal is a greater sin as compared to
killing a plant so I told him brother
suppose you have a younger brother who
born deaf and dumb two senses less after
he grows up if someone goes and kills
him will you tell the judge oh me Lord
give the murderer less punishment
because my brother had two sentences L
will you say that you will say may Lord
give him double punishment because he
killed a person who was innocent so in
Islam the logic doesn't work like that
two senses or three senses Islam says in
Surah Bak 2 vers 168 eat of the good
things that we have provided for you
that means whatever is good and lawful
you can have and that's the reason if
you analyze the cattle in the world
Allah subhana wa ta'ala has his way
Almighty God the reproduction of the
cattle is very fast as compared to
reproduction of the other animals and
the human beings the reproduce very fast
if I agree with you that no human being
should have any cattle then we will have
overp population of cattle in the world
and regarding killing of cows there's a
book written by m Abdul Kim
parik GAA cow slaughter who is to blame
and you analyze the people that deal in
leather leather of cows more non-muslim
than Muslims leather the Jens they deal
in that so the people are responsible to
benefit from the cow slaughter and not
the Muslims the more of them are
non-muslims so if you know history well
and if you know logic also well you'll
understand that Allah says eat of the
good things we have provided for you if
you can have there's no problem and
besides that if you analyze the set of
teeth of the herous
animal the cow the goat the Sheep they
only have vegetables they have a flat
set of teeth if you analyze the set of
teeth of the Carnivor animal the lion
the tiger the leopard they have got
sharp pointed teeth they can only have
non-w if you analyze the set of teeth of
the human beings if you go in the mirror
and look at your teeth we have pointed
teeth as well as flat teeth if almighty
God wanted us to have only vegetables
why did he give us this pointed teeth
for what to have
nonv if you analyze the diive system of
the herbivorous animal the cow the goat
the Sheep they have diis system which
can only digest vegetables the dice
system of the carnivorous animal the
lion the tiger the leopard they can only
digest nonv the DI system of the human
beings can digest both non-v and veg if
almighty God wanted us to have only
vegetables why did he give us a d system
that can digest both wge and non-w so
scientifically if you analyze almighty
God wanted us to have both wedge as well
as non- wedge hope that answers the
question if you have any queries any
other misconception brother it's my
pleasure to reply one misconception at
time so that I can do justice to each of
the misconception thank you
brother
yes hello
Dr
Excuse excuse me brother excuse me let
me coordinate we have been called here
Zak has been invited by the organizers
here to give a talk in English and have
a question answer that what questions
you have to address I would request you
to kindly after the program address to
the
organizer so you put forward a
question question put forward inshah
speaker he'll explain English and answer
it
Universal
Brotherhood
goding g o that super power is
controlling the nature and that nature
is having three parts g o d God G for
generator o for operator D for Destroyer
that nature is generating us that nature
is operating us that nature is
destroying us we are being generated we
are being operated we are being
destroyed is my goddess or God
mean
very much thank you very much brother
the brother has summarized my lecture in
a very short way alhamdulillah I thank
him he rightly said there's no god and
goddess that's what I explained he
explained in Hindi so that those who
don't understand English can understand
I would like to thank you brother he
explained very well there's no God
there's no goddess Allah tala Allah
subhana tal is superior and I agree with
him thank you brother and he rightly
said that there should not be different
religions I agree with you they should
not be different religions because Quran
says in Surah Al Iman chter 3 verse
number
19 Islam the only way of life acceptable
is the person who submits his will to
Allah subhana wa ta'ala and I agree with
you brother that if you fight amongst
yourself in religion there's bound to be
differences and there should be no
differences and the brother also made
certain comments that Shia Etc and
different religion and 73 FAS I can give
that answer it requires time if you want
to know the answer you can pose it I'll
give you the reply for that also why
talk about different F Etc but the
brother rightly says that there should
be only one religion one way of life and
that is submitting your will to Allah
subhana wa
taala if you believe in that there has
to be Universal Brotherhood if you don't
believe in that there's bound to be
disharmony thank you very much brother
Zak I have a very simple question your
name uh Professor
D I have not studied any religion I
don't believe in any
religion I my simple question is do you
believe that there are different
religions and there have to be different
religions because in your lecture you
said that the Allah the God
Almighty created all the people in the
world men and women and he purposely
divided them into different
religions different regions etc etc so
that they should not fight with each
other but they should understand each
other will you kindly explain to me the
purpose of the
Crusades and will you kind kindly
explain to me your own statement that
the difference between Hinduism and the
Islam religion you said that it is
Hinduism and it is Islam religion you
never said that Hinduism is a
religion the difference which you stated
between Hinduism and Islam religion was
that Hindus believe that everything is
God while Muslims believe that
everything is
Gods if everything is Gods why there is
so much of killing either in India or in
any other part of the whole world even
in the Muslim countries also thank you
very much that's very good question
and he said that I said my talk that the
almighty God has created the human being
from a single pair male and female and
I've divided into different religions
brother never did I said almighty God
divided the people in different
religions it been recorded I never said
different religions I said into
different nations and
tribes races in colors not religion
Allah say there's only one religion
almighty God never divide the people in
different religions there's only one
religion into different nations and
colors and variation in languages so
that you may recognize each other so
that you may know this person he comes
from this particular race from this
region not religion region it is not
religion so your statement of religion
is not other things is fine different
languages different colors different
nations I agree with that so that they
may recognize each other not that they
should fight amongst each other you said
that I never mentioned that Hinduism a
religion
I again disagree with you I said
religion is a belief in almighty God o
for dictionary to understand Hinduism to
understand the religion of Hinduism you
have to understand the concept of God to
understand the religion of Judaism you
have to understand the concept of God
and Judaism to understand the religion
of Christianity you have to understand
the concept of God and Christianity to
understand the religion of Islam you
have to understand the concept of God in
Islam that's what I
said regarding differences who has
created not almighty God Allah clearly
says in Surah Anam 6: 159 anyone who
breaks the religion into sex Allah has
nothing to do with him you cannot divide
the religion anyone who divides is in
the wrong you ask me why are people
killing each other you have to ask them
suppose as a teacher you tell the people
don't copy and yet they copy who's to
blame the teacher or the student the
student here almighty God has given a
free will to the human beings that you
can do what you want I've given you
Guidance the last and final
Guidance the last and final Revelation
is the Glorious Quran the dos and do is
mentioned here and Allah says and I
mentioned my talk in Sur ma 5:32 if
anyone kills a human being whether it be
a Muslim or non-muslim whether it be
Hindu Jew Christian sik anyone unless it
be for murder or for spreading Mischief
in the land it is as though he has
killed the whole of human race if he
saves any human being it is as though he
has saved the whole of humanity so God
Almighty doesn't like people killing
each other but if human beings don't
want to follow who's to blame the human
beings so this word the Quran says in
Surah mul chapter 16 verse number two
that this world Allah has created death
and life to test which of you is good in
Deeds Allah has created death and life
to test which of you is good in Deeds
Allah doesn't interfere if he wants he
can
the Quran says if Allah wanted he could
have made all the people believe but
then where's the test if the teacher
wants he can easily pass all those
students irres whether they fail teacher
can but that will be bi then where is
the Free Will of the student if they're
undergoing a test and if someone doesn't
give a right answer yet the teacher
passes then a person who studied hard
will object that eyes clocked so much
for the examination this person is
coping and he's cheating he wres the
wrong answer and you pass him so next
batch if the people realize the teacher
passes everyone irrespective whether you
give right answer or wrong answer then
everyone will stop studying then you may
get a degree a medical degree but that
doctor when he passes his medical when
he comes out he will not cure the people
he will kill the people so therefore
Allah subhana tala has given the
guidelines in the Glorious Quran do not
kill do not harm other love people love
your neighbors all that my talk but if
people don't do that means they are not
following the Quran let it be
anyone let it be anyone whether it be
Amica whether it be Pakistan whether it
be any country in the world people may
say see just by calling yourself a
Muslim name Abdullah or Zak or Muhammad
you don't tiet to Jenna that's by saying
that you are a Muslim doesn't make you a
Muslim Muslim is not a label that okay
if I say I'm Muslim I'm Muslim Muslim
means a person who submits his will to
Allah subana tala just by calling a
person Zakir Abdullah Muhammad Shak
these people if they act if they submit
their will to Allah then they are
Muslims by calling thems Muslims as the
Quran says there are some people or lips
of with Muslim so if people are killing
they are not following the guidance of
the Quran if they follow the guidance of
the Quran peace will prevail throughout
the world hope the answer the question
so
Zak if a
Hindu follows the principles of
Quran which are very similar to the
principles given in the various Hindu
religious books can a Hindu call himself
as a Muslim or on the other hand can a
Muslim call himself as a Hindu because
you are the very topic of your lecture
is universal Brotherhood I properly
understood Dr
vas when he asked his question very good
question brother if you ask a clear
question I can give a reply
alhamdulillah but they asked a very good
question can a Hindu following the
principles of Islam in the Quran and
Hinduism be called as a Muslim and can a
Muslim be called as a Hindu very good
let's understand the definition of the
word Muslim and a Hindu as I said muslim
is a person who submits his will to
Allah subhana waala almighty God what
the definition of the word Hindu do you
know Hindu is a geographical definition
anyone living in India anyone living on
this side of the indust valley
civilization he's a Hindu by definition
I'm a Hindu do you know
that Hindu is a geographical definition
you ask anyone according to Swami vianda
Hindu is a Mis Noma geographically I'm a
Indian I'm a Hindu geographically but
Swami vianda said that they should be
called as
vedantist they should not be called
Hindus viantis so if you ask me am I
geographically Hindu yes I'm
geographically Hindu I am but if you ask
me am I a wanst following the vas I said
that those those parts of The Vedas
which conciliate with the Glorious Quran
I've got no objection following those
parts for example that there is one God
but if you say I believe that almighty
God created the Brahman from the head a
different cast which are superior cast
the chrias from the chest it's V I'm
quoting if you don't believe in the Veda
it's your problem brother but this is
the V I'm quoting you can ask the
scholars of Vin Scholars they sitting
here they're sitting here vas say that
not I the wayas from the thighs and the
sudras from the feet so I don't agree
with this
concept that's right so if you ask me do
you believe in the philosophy of I said
no this particular philosophy according
to anybody who inhabits this land is a
Hindu yes yes geographically said that
everybody should be yes brother rightly
said that anyone who inhabits India has
to be Hindu but natur
anyone Living in America he a citizen of
America he has to be American very good
alhamdulillah so anyone
living yes that's it I agree with you
brother geographically everyone living
in India is a Hindu so I completely
agree with it by the geographical
definition if you say if you say that
anyone who lives in India is Hindu it's
correct any scholar will agree anyone
living in India is Hindu geographically
I'm a Hindu but because I stay in India
can I be a Muslim yes pleas main it of
course so a person can a Muslim be a
Hindu yes if the Muslim is living in
India he can be a Hindu but if a
so-called Hindu lives in America he's
not a Hindu you know that he's an
American so Hinduism cannot be called a
universal religion according to the
scholars Hindu is the religion of India
only it's not a religion it's a
geographical definition according to
Swami vianda who's a great scholar he
said Hinduism is a misn NOA you know
misn NOA misn NOA means a wrong label
given they should be called as viantis
so if you ask me am I a Hindu I will
tell you if Hindu is a person living in
India by all means I'm a Hindu but if
you say Hindu is a person who worships
as the person said you know that if you
believe in so and so Gods who have got
forms Etc and have got heads and hands
Etc then I'm not a Hindu but if you mean
a geographical definition yes I'm a
Hindu similarly can a Hindu be a Muslim
yes a Indian can be a
Muslim a Hindu can be a Muslim but if
that
Indian if that Indian does idol worship
he can't be a Muslim because the Quran
says in n 4:48 and Sur n 4: 116 that
Allah subhana wa ta'ala never forgives
the sin of committing shik associating
Partners any other sin if he wishes he
may forgive but sh he'll never forgive
so an Indian living in India
geographical Hindu can be a Muslim but
if that geographical Hindu Indian breaks
any Commandments that is the basics of
concept of God believe in Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam then he
cannot be a Muslim any Muslim who
follows the Quran and lives in India
he's an Indian Muslim hope it's very
clear for you
he's Hindu
Muslim two things I want to make very
clear first you might have might not
have properly heard
me uh brother uh I think as far as the
question answer session goes we'll allow
normally one question you put your
question completely as a question rather
than lecture and let the speaker answer
after the question answer session is
over after the program is over and when
others who might not be interested
discussion we'll welcome discussion
after the program so everyone else is
not blocked up on one question and we
give opportunity to many other
people yes
advate
answer
excuse me brother is brother excuse me
I'll put forward the question on the
slip Mr metas why are most of the
Muslims fundamentalists and terrorists
the question posed is by Brother meta
why are most of the Muslims
fundamentalist and terrorist the
question is posed I give the answer if
you like it you take it if you don't
like it leave it Quran says in Surah Bak
CH 2 verse number
256 there is no compulsion religion
truth stands out clear from error I
present the truth to you if you like it
you take it if you don't like it you
reject it no problem there is no
compulsion religion
like 2: 256 brother Met has asked a
question that why are most of the Muslim
fundamentalist why are the
terrorists what is the meaning of the
word
fundamentalist fundamentalist is a
person who follows the fundamentals
for example a person to be a good
mathematician you should know he should
follow and practice the fundamentals of
maths he should be a fundamentalist in
the field of maths to be a good
mathematician for a person to be a good
scientist he should know he should
follow and practice the fundamentals of
science he should be a fundamentalist in
the field of science to be a good
scientist for a person to be a good
doctor he should know he should follow
and practice the fundamentals of
medicine he should be a fundamentalist
in the field of medicine to be a good
doctor you cannot paint all
fundamentalists with the same brush you
can't say all fundamentalists are bad or
all fundamentalists are good for example
you have a fundamentalist robber who's
expert in the field of
robbing but he's harmful for the society
he robs the people and doesn't promote
Brotherhood he is not a good human being
on the other hand you have a
fundamentalist doctor who follows and
practice the fundamentals of medicine
and he cures the sickness of human
beings he is a good
person he helps the human being so you
can't paint all fundamentalist with the
same
brush regarding Muslim the
fundamentalist I am proud to be a
fundamentalist Muslim because I know I
follow and alhamdulillah strive to
practice the fundamentals of Islam I'm
proud to be a fundamentalist Muslim and
every Muslim to be a good Muslim should
be a fundamentalist Muslim otherwise he
can't be a good Muslim every Hindu to be
a good Hindu he should be a
fundamentalist Hindu otherwise he not be
a good Hindu every Christian to be a
good Christian he should be a
fundamentalist Christian otherwise he
won't be a good Christian regarding is a
fundamentalist Muslim good or bad that
the question
alhamdulillah the fundamentals of Islam
the there is not a single fundamental of
Islam which is Against Humanity so far
many of the brothers posst certain
questions because of the misconception
because of the misconception you may
think that this teaching of Islam is
wrong like brother said having C is
wrong and I gave the answer brother said
about certain things and I gave the
answer so person who has lack of
knowledge he may think that there are
certain fundamental of Islam which are
wrong but if anyone who has the
knowledge of Islam there is not a single
teachings of Islam which goes against
humanity goes against Society I
challenge anyone not only in this
audience in the full Universe to point
out to me a single a single teaching of
Islam which is against the basics of
humanity single some people may feel bad
but as a whole the teaching of Islam is
best for Universal Brotherhood to
promote Humanity there is not a single
teaching and a challenge again anyone
from the audience they can ask me
questions I will clarify the
misconception inshallah when the time
comes there the next question you can
post one question at a time when your
turn was there you don't reply see the
thing is that you have to follow certain
rules the mic was empty for half an hour
no one came up I told the brother you're
most welcome you stand on the mic no one
comes you can keep on asking one one
question every third question will be
your question no problem you can ask as
many as as much as the time the aori has
been had for there's no
problem so I'm proud to be a
fundamentalist Muslim but if you read
the definition of
fundamentalism in the web dictionary it
says that fundamentalism was a movement
which was started in the early 20th
century by a group of Christian the
Protestants in America who protested and
said that not only is the Bible the
teachings of Bible the word of God but
every letter of the Bible is wor in the
word of God so fundamentalism was first
for a group of protestant Christians in
America who protested and said that
every letter word of the Bible is the
word of God if any human being who can
prove that every word of the Bible is a
word of God then the movement is good
but if someone can prove that every word
of the Bible is not the word of God then
the movement is not a good movement but
if you read the Oxford
Dictionary what is the meaning of the
word
fundamentalism fundamentalism according
to O for dis means strictly adhering to
ancient laws of any religion especially
Islam in Oxford dictionary they write
especially Islam the word especially
Islam is there in the latest edition of
Oxford dictionary that means
fundamentalist immediately think of a
Muslim why the media is bombarding
people that you know that these Muslims
they are fundamentalist they terrorist
the moment you think they were are
fundamentalist immediate medely people
start thinking of a Muslim start
thinking of the word terrorist and if
you analyze many of times two different
labels are given to the same person for
his same activity for
example you know there were many Indians
who fought for the freedom of India when
the britishers ruled India there were
many Indians who fought for the freedom
of
India the britishers called them as
terrorists these people are terrorists
but we Indians we call these Freedom
Fighters as Patriots right or wrong
Patriots they fought for the freedom of
the country same people same activity
two different labels the britishers call
them as terrorist the Indian citizens
call them as Patriots Freedom Fighters
same activity same person two different
labels so before you give a label you
should first Analyze That which view do
you adhere to if you agree with the
British view that the British government
had a right to rule over India then you
would call these people as terrorist but
if you agree with the Indian citizens
that the britishers they came to do
business and they started ruling us
unlawfully then you'll call these people
as Freedom Fighters so before you give
any label to any particular person
should analyze which view do you have
same people can be given two different
views by different people in this
context I would say every Muslim should
be a fundamental list where Islam is
concerned because every teaching of
Islam promotes human values and humanity
and Universal brother hope the answer
the question